well firstly you get a flavor just how
serious the situation is there's
absolutely a real threat uh from russia
across the border that hasn't dissipated
as you were just outlining but there's
also a huge recognition and appreciation
for the support coming from britain
that's very very obvious indeed but the
penny is dropping too that ukraine is at
the epicenter if you like of the clash
between western liberalism and
authoritarianism there is a much bigger
picture at clay which i think the west
is now beginning to appreciate and if we
blink where could uh this uh take us
it's too late to bring in a nato
division as i call for i recognize that
but the west i think needs to ask
themselves what more
can we do perhaps look at a no-fly zone
certainly defense spending will have to
increase as the world does get more
dangerous but it's this bigger alliance
between russia and china it's through
that prism that we need to look at
events here in ukraine
did want to um i know that you are uh
quite close with lord donate you've been
speaking to him quite a lot over the
last few days given that you've been
you've brought up the troops there i
just wanted to play this grab to you
from what he said to us earlier on in
the week and see where that puts us now
here we go i shouldn't smile um you're
not the first person to ask me um about
tomorrow's elwood
actually i rang tobias about 20 minutes
ago and said come on chuck what are you
getting on about
and that was when we were talking of
course about troops on the ground in um
ukraine
and particularly uh around kiev the
capital what would you say in response
to him
well we did have a conversation and
we're actually saying the same thing
it's far too late uh i was calling for
this months and months ago when the
build-up of troops of russian troops uh
was evident uh there's a process that
has to be followed uh we need to take
the british people with us to recognize
that yes
this is a high-risk strategy but
ultimately it would prevent an invasion
you're not starting a war you're
actually preventing a russian attack and
that must be a good thing nato is all
about european security and ukraine as
part of europe the consequences of not
doing anything allowing that evasion
invasion to actually take place will
have massive implications for the uk
economy oil gas food prices will go up
but like i said there's a bigger picture
at play at where russia is going its
alliance with china will is a turning
point if you like uh in our security on
the international stage and i think
privately the international community is
regretting not stepping forward but we
still can act we still can offer a
no-fly zone and critically this
initiative that britain has put forward
the last time the prime minister was
here this alliance between poland
ukraine and britain is something that's
very very important indeed that needs to
be explored as to how we can support the
ukrainian people if we do nothing and
allow an invasion to take place it will
have i think a totemic effect on
european security this is a serious
moment and uh we're being tested
lord dana also said that we shouldn't
allow ukraine to join nato the german
chancellor schultz who was in moscow as
you know speaking to president putin
this week he seemed to hint at that as
well where do you stand on that debate
well we need to get over this idea that
we hide behind the excuse that because a
nation is not in nato that they don't
deserve some form of serious support
libya for example um kosovo uh bosnia
iraq afghanistan these are all places
that we went in as nato capability but
they're not members of nato but there
were security concerns here so we need
to stop hiding behind this the west has
become too risk-averse over the months
indeed the years itself i'd even call
for a casablanca type conference if you
like because you've got berlin paris
london and washington still looking in
slightly different directions and that's
being exploited uh by putin in moscow
what's the casablanca conference
well this happened during the second
world war it was before you even decided
what you wanted to do you made sure that
the home team was pointing in the same
direction so yes we've threatened the
sanctions but if you understand the
bigger picture if
uh putin is wanting to realign his
country with china sanctions will only
help him persuade the russian people
look our future is not with the west
it's actually with china we don't need
that nordstrom 2 going across to the
western europe we can have three of
those with china and of course they have
scant regard for human rights issues and
so on
an equal disdain for the west and that
alliance as i say i can't be stronger in
what mean my concerns here that new
alliance will have a massive implication
for geopolitical security over the next
few decades
there was a day of unity yesterday in uh
ukraine and kiev particularly some
concerns that yesterday was going to be
the day that there was an incursion an
invasion that didn't happen thankfully
um
but what what's the mood there like as
an outsider as a westerner if you will
um what are you picking up
well when you first come here you can
feel the tension there's no doubt about
it the threat is very very real indeed
but there's a stoic sense of
determination here don't forget the
people here have been living with this
for years and years and years with the
war going on but a crisis you know could
break out at any moment and uh
contingency plans are in place there is
an absolute worry and i think privately
there is a desire to
you know call for the west to do more
this is their moment of need and at the
moment the west is not doing enough
and doing more looks like what
well like i said initially a no-fly zone
would be held very very helpful indeed
that is something i hope that could be
explored at the munich security
conference certainly as each day goes by
and an invasion doesn't take place we
should be absolutely supporting um
ukraine as i say that bond between
poland uh ukraine and britain is
something that absolutely wants to be
explored that's something you can ask
james heapey about that alliance there
could be the genesis of uh and include
the baltics as well of a new strength of
support of security in eastern europe
but i i stress this is a the bigger
picture taking place here it's not just
about ukraine this is about global
security and where our world goes to as
our international rules-based order will
be reinterpreted by russia and china if
they form this axis over the coming
months and years
but you are stepping back now are you uh
miss del wood from uk boots on the
ground
i i made that very clear that that was
an option that option has departed we
simply cannot do that when i first
raised this at the end of last year yes
and speaking to military uh senior
military leaders uh in both in britain
and uh and the united states absolutely
it could have happened it would have
taken five days to actually mobilize
those forces at the request of ukraine
this is what they actually wanted to but
we blinked we didn't appreciate that
full picture we didn't have the
situational awareness to say my goodness
this is not just about ukraine there's
something else going on here the west is
now appreciating that there's no doubt
about it but i worry that still isn't
fully understood like i said any
sanctions that are imposed on to to
russia they will retaliate and it will
give putin the excuse to pivot his
country away from the west towards an
alliance with china
mr elwood uh it's good to talk to you
thank you for joining us this morning
thank you